car mon sujet de ce jour c'est je n'ai
pas d'identité
alors comme il a été dit je m'appelle
rennes je suis né en février 1981 et à
ma naissance pour attribuer un patronyme
qui s'appelle et sauves magic qui figure
sur mon acte de naissance
c'est la première identité que l'on m'a
donné cette identité indien de mon père
cet acte de naissance il est un athée
l'essence qui parle des parents qui
m'ont mis au monde donc on perdu ma mère
qui ont choisi mes différents prénom
j'en ai trois ça fait un petit peu
beaucoup
je n'ai pas d'identité à 17 ans mes
parents m'ont envoyé en france pour
poursuivre mes études dumont bac à 17
ans et j'ai poursuivi mes études en
france qui fait un bts informatique
industrielle alors lorsque je suis
arrivé dans cette filière
nous étions deux filles sur un groupe de
trois de ses élèves et en informatique
industrielle à l'époque n'avait pas
encore plus de fonds venir dans cette
rivière
alors nos collègues nous disait parfois
nos camarades de classe que nous
n'avions rien à faire dans cette classe
parmi ses deux filles il y avait une
blanche et noire qui est témoin qui
venait d'afrique
donc vous voyez un petit peu la
différence je me souviens un jour je
suis arrivé avec mon afro sur la tête et
mes camarades était tellement surpris
qu'ils ont voulu toucher mes cheveux
parce qu'ils n'avaient jamais vu
quelqu'un avec un arbre on sert on dire
un petit peu je n'ai pas d'identité
après l'inde le bts en informatique et
embuscades je suis
rentré en cycle ingénieur et là nous
étions neuf ans ont deux filles faut
savoir que notre école est une école
électronique alors dans les écoles
d'ingénieur de l'école d'électronique
est très spécifique dans des métiers qui
sont est un mot nation et là on nous
disait parfois sous la forme blague
après méchamment que nous n'avions pas
de faciès de l'emploi parce que ça
allait bien que s'il ya une trame dans
les domaines scientifiques et aux bonus
et marie curie et que marie curie à son
époux avait un certain look d'avoir une
idée pas noir et qu'en plus elle avait
ses terres auxerre qui caractérise et
les femmes scientifiques
donc lorsqu'on se présentait on ne
ressemblait pas on n'avait pas cette
crédibilité des trains des femmes dans
le de même que nous étudions je n'ai pas
d'identité parce qu'après mon diplôme
d'ingénieur en télécoms et réseaux
j'ai commencé à travailler dans des
entreprises dans ce même domaine
spécifique à faire du conseil
la première entreprise dans laquelle
j'ai travaillé nous étions deux femmes
sont de 2 soit un chiffre qui me suivent
beaucoup machette et moi et la veille
j'avais un groupe de messieurs qui nous
expliquait que nous n'avions quasiment
rien à faire dans ce secteur et qu'en
particulier nous n'avions ni la
crédibilité ni l'identité de l'emploi je
me souviens certains de mes clients des
premières missions que je faisais on
allait faire des raccordements de câbles
fibre optique dans des baies c'est un
peu technique et ces messieurs me
regarde et me disaient mais vous êtes
monté est ce que vous cherchez le
département de la communication est ce
que vous cherchez le département du
marketing
qu'est ce que vous venez faire dans
cette salle technique dans ce lot
techni que l'on appelle aujourd'hui
couramment les locaux techniques donc
les salles informatiques ou les data
center je n'ai pas d'identité parce que
à l'époque quand j'ai commencé à
travailler
un consultant expérimenté m'avait
conseillé d'avoir un pc la roulette pour
transporter mon pc m'a expliqué que le
fait d'avoir laissé les documents ça
pouvait oser des effets à long terme en
particulier quand on est une femme au
niveau du dos j'ai commencé à travailler
le premier à charge avait fait c'est est
ce que ça a roulé et quand j'arrive
parfois on me demandait si j'étais
hôtesse de l'air on se demandait ce que
je vais faire alors par la suite j'ai
travaillé dans dans une entreprise qui
fait des audits de sida sécurité et je
me souviens qu'une fois j'ai débarqué
c'était n'était en europe
donc j'avais une europe et m'ont baissé
et le monsieur m'a regardé comme si vous
voyez une apparition elle m'a dit on
attend l'expert vous faire l'audit de
sécurité jeudi passé noir voilà je n'ai
pas d'identité à la suite de cette
première expérience professionnelle j'ai
créé mon entreprise en 2009 30 janvier
et lorsque j'ai créé cette entreprise
suis tout de suite voulu travailler en
afrique
donc j'ai commencé à travailler sur des
projets financés par les bailleurs de
fonds ont des projets financés à la
banque
on est souvent dans mes équipes
je faisais appel à des consultants
externes des experts qui venaient
travailler donc sur ces différents
projets je n'arrive à plusieurs reprises
lorsqu'on allait rencontrer les clients
les ministres les autorités de certains
pays que non on interpelle les experts
qui avaient en commun d'être souvent des
hommes parfois blanc et tous au dessus
de 45 ans vouloir demander de venir
introduire la société qui avait gagné le
projet je n'ai pas d'identité parce que
je n'ai pas le profil
le faciès de la chef d'entreprise en
conseil en informatique et télécom qui
veut gagner des gros projets pour des
gouvernements dans le cadre de la
stratégie donc un numérique met en
oeuvre
je n'ai pas d'identité parce que lorsque
je me suis marié
on nous a fait signer un papier
indiquant qu'elle était notre nouveau
nom et là mon patronyme avait encore
songé donc et son ag a disparu mbangue
est devenu moins ne faut pas trop ligne
voilà je n'ai pas d'identité parce que
lorsqu'on part d'identité je vous ai
parlé de mon identité physique mais on a
eu notre identité qui est une identité
numérique
ce que l'on voit sur les réseaux sociaux
il m'arrive souvent de rencontrer des
personnes qui me parle de mon profil sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui me parle un
petit peu de ce que je fais elles sont
toujours émerveillés par ce qu'ils me
disent nous sur ces réseaux sociaux on
voit une personne qui parcours
différents pays
qui fait énormément de choses qui a
l'air d'être brillante courageuse forte
intelligente et souvent je me demande si
nous avons tous la même version
la section de qui est cette personne
évidemment voyez dans une journée il y
avait un intervalle dans une heure il ya
68 e et dans ses minutes il ya soixante
secondes
photo k cuire 1 h 30 et une fraction de
seconde
alors c'est à dire de second disque est
traduit d'éléments qui est une personne
qu'est ce que cette empreinte ces traces
numériques traduise réellement qui je
suis parfois quand il me parle je n'ai
pas l'impression que nous parlons tous
les deux de la même personne
je n'ai pas d'identité parce que parmi
ces personnes avec lesquelles j'ai
changé il ya une catégorie les femmes en
particulier qui est une catégorie de
population avec laquelle j'aime
énormément échangé qui me parlent qui me
fait des retours je suis intéressé par
cette catégorie de personnes parce que
j'ai été très long dans minorité dans le
monde des femmes ingénieurs et
scientifiques est en réalité je n'ai pas
d'identité parce que en échangeant avec
elle je me retrouve dans chacune d'entre
elles les difficultés et défis et donc
les craintes qu'elle peur le fait de ne
pas savoir si on va y arriver dans la
durée dans le temps
à l'instant t lorsqu'on démarre un
projet d'activité le pen sûr qu'on va
pouvoir regarder parce que tout autour
de vous vous dit que vous n'avez pas le
faciès vous n'êtes pas taillé pour
l'emploi n'est pas taillé pour le job
alors je n'ai pas l'identité parce qu'en
réalité s'ils ont chacune en l2 se
retrouve mon identité et que comme
certaines ont pu me tenir la main et
m'encouragent et me pousser vers l'avant
en réalité notre identité c'est
puissance de la somme hobbit et le fait
de pouvoir nous soutenir nous tenir les
coudes nous encourager et aller ensemble
de l'avant lorsqu'on part d'identité
en réalité on a dans notre monde actuel
prix d'identité comme étant quelque
chose qui est une particule
l'idée mais si vous cherchez la
définition du mot d'identité vous
rendrez compte que identité comme
identiques veut dire ce qui est romain
en réalité ce n'est pas que le créancier
c'est ce qui est commun à chacun de nous
et ce qui est commun chacun d'entre nous
sénèque at-il tant que nous vivons parmi
les hommes pratiquent dans l'humanité
c'est cette particularité c'est le fait
que nous soyons humains et en tant
qu'humain qu'est ce que nous voulons en
réalité ce que nous voulons c'est qu'on
peut construire une société un monde
inclusif un monde juste un monde
équitable à manque d'opportunités de
possibilités aux toutes les personnes
quelles qu'elles soient en fonction pas
en fonction de leurs jambes en fonction
de l' identité d'entités telles que
définies par notre état civil ou rock
mais simplement en fonction de ce que
nous pourrons apporter à cette société
alors je n'ai pas d'identité parce qu'en
réalité mon identité
elle se construit des échanges de jets
avec toutes les personnes que je réponds
en ou femmes de ces interactions
parfois je me retrouve en m comme dans
un miroir
parfois elle me projette une image de
moins que je n'apprécie pas et qui me
permet de me corriger
en réalité je n'ai pas d'identité parce
que mon identité
elle est dans chaque personne que l'on
rencontre elle se construit au fur et à
mesure elle n'est pas encore parfaite
elle
sera peut-être à l'auscultation monde
mais c'est identité en réalité c'est
celle de tous les échanges c'est celle
de toute la richesse humaine de toute la
diversité des changes conservant 30 et
ça monte ça s'appelle d'humanité voilà
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]